this pistol the Armada x1 and it's RFID
watch are sold as one of the most secure
firearm systems available the IP one
requires the watch to be present in
order to fire if the watch is absent the
gun does not fire in contrast if you
have the watch on your wrist and the
watch is held within one foot of the
pistol then we pick it up go to fire it
does like others so called smart guns
it's designed so that it can only be
fired by its owner in theory but a
security researcher who goes by the
pseudonym ploor has found flaws in the
arm ah --tx with high and low tech that
entirely defeat its security measures he
intends to present his findings at this
year's hacker conference DEFCON not only
wasn't insecure it was insecure in a way
that was easier than I had anticipated
he found ways to extend the range of the
watch's connection to the pistol to jam
the guns radio signals preventing it
from firing even when the shooter is
wearing the watch and most alarmingly to
fire the pistol without the watch at all
by using simple and cheap magnets before
finding the magnet attack ploor use more
technically complex tricks so I'm a
background in an embedded software and a
better hardware and so I have the
instruments and the knowledge to find
these vulnerabilities pleure used
sophisticated signal analysis
instruments and found the exact
frequency that the watch uses to
communicate with the pistol there we are
when I squeeze the back strap and I scan
over the right spot
we see that signal on the oscilloscope
at about a five point three five
kilohertz for about a millisecond and a
half floor built a relay that listens
for the watch's signal to the pistol
intercepts it and replays it from
another relay 10 or 12 feet away
dangerously extending the range of the
authentication watch one of the devices
goes near the watch the other device is
held near the pistol so even though
we're now several feet from the watch
ordinarily the gun will not fire but
since we have the relay it will ploor
also found the watch's signal
authorizing the pistol to fire so after
finding the waveform with a signal
generator in the spectrum analyzer I set
up to a miniature eyes it and came up
with this circuit the circuit happens to
use the same Trancy
module used in the pistol on the wash to
generate a single at nine hundred and
sixteen point five megahertz and by
generating that same frequency the
circuit jams the watch and pistols
connection preventing the gun from
firing ordinarily the pistol will fire
as long as it's close enough to a watch
and the watch has been enabled however
if you have a neighbor or an adversary
operating in the same frequency band
it won't work as intended to simulate
this I've built a transmitter here
operating the same frequency band at the
watch in the pistol use so I'm gonna
turn it on place it here and step back
some distance and although the gun would
ordinarily fire from this distance it
does not know the ploor also found a
surprisingly simple vulnerability that
makes it possible to fire the pistol
without the watch at all even if the gun
has been stolen from its owner magnets I
take the magnet and place it on the
pistol in the right spot it does fire so
essentially with $15 with the magnets I
cracked a fifteen hundred dollar smart
gun Plourd dug-up are mah Texas patents
and tore down the gun and located the
electromagnetic locking mechanism of the
pistols firing pin so this electromagnet
is actuated by the microcontroller
in the pistol grip when it receives an
authentication token from the watch
ordinarily there's no attraction the
magnet is off however when we squeeze
the grip and pull the trigger halfway
the main is activated and a paperclip
will stick to it this is the side of the
gun when the triggers pull partway this
is depressed lifting the silver part the
silver part is ferrous mean they'll be
attracted by the electromagnet that we
saw earlier however if you take a really
big external magnet we can stand in for
the electromagnet and doesn't matter if
the gun is authorized to fire it doesn't
matter if the gun has batteries in it
with the external magnet in place then
we pull the trigger partway the external
magnet pulls the ferrous material
further unblocking the firing pin
allowing the gun to fire when the hammer
strikes the firing pin hacking the watch
and pistols communication requires a
number of expensive tools but the
magnets can be bought online by anyone
so there's an ethical dilemma in hacking
about what
there we should sit on the information
that we learn or other rather we should
share it with the world on the one hand
kid might not know how to do this attack
and you might be teaching them how to do
it on the other hand a kid might
discover independently and the parents
would be unaware of it it's even being
possible so we have to balance that
between the needs know and they need to
be able to fix things gun control groups
have been pushing for smart gun adoption
for years but many gun rights advocates
strongly oppose them fearing that a
flawed expensive technology will be
legally mandated so personally I believe
that you should be able to own a smart
gun if you want one but you should not
be required to own a smart gun and if
you do to choose to buy a smart gun it
should at least do what it claims to do
plural eart Adar mod x the german
company that makes the IP one about the
flaws in the pistols design our mod X
acknowledged plaus findings to Wired and
didn't dispute that the attacks were
possible they argued that in some cases
the security breaches he demonstrated
wouldn't be easy or practical a
spokesperson writes our experiences with
the strengths and weaknesses of the IP 1
system will flow into the next
generation of smart guns system while
poor is demonstrating potentially
dangerous flaws in the our mod x IP 1 he
says he takes comfort and knowing that
very few of the guns have sold so far he
hopes his findings can serve as an early
warning and will help to secure future
smart guns before they become widely
adopted so ask for other guns so to mark
our other smart guns I'd love to get a
hold of them and test them out see how
secure they really are my hope is that
manufacturers going forward won't rely
on the sort of a taxi you can mount with
a simple magnet more complicated
mechanisms like motor drives might be
more appropriate if smart guns are ever
going to become standard in other words
they'll have to be smarter than this one
[Applause]